my name is Dylan I'm from the US I live
in Phoenix Arizona like to start so the
talk is react plus five scripts all
start with react so I think if you had
to answer in one slide what's good about
react I would probably go with this that
the reactive architecture is good things
are very modular very separable you have
a number of loosely coupled libraries
that can be made to work together in a
fairly consistent manner it leverages
modern JavaScript and of course it has
probably the most vibrant JavaScript
community ever in the history of
JavaScript as much as we've been
fragmented over the past 15 or 20 years
we're quite unified more than ever
around react and reactive architectures
if you had to sort of look at like
what's wrong with react and also
reduction there just because I can
there's a lot of challenges around
building large-scale react applications
or I imagine if everyone who raised
their hand and said they use react got
together and said okay what packages do
I use how is your application actually
architected what component library to
use how do you if you got together and
did all of that you probably have quite
different answers unless you all work
for the same company any of if you do
work for the same company might have
quite a few differences and I think
there's just a number of challenges
around building large scale applications
for three-act because there are so many
decisions and there's not a lot of sort
of forced architecture in place and I
think that's both its strength and its
weakness so I was reminded of this I
gave a talk at JSF that the video should
be out soon called react already did
that was kind of a humorous look at the
history of JavaScript it wasn't really
about react at all but the slide I liked
was from Yanni who talked and minded
everyone how poorly reacted was received
five years ago and so these were some of
the initial tweets like basically oh my
god JSX why just so I stopped ruining
j/s people I wonder if larnice own who
commented on that in May of 2013 still
feels that way or if he's embracing
react would be cool to find out but you
know this is terrible so we really not
learned anything from PHP tips right so
people really don't like change and they
don't like things that
new well the reason I mentioned this is
typescript came out that same year and
typescript had a similar polarizing
reaction from people people either
immediately saw the promise of it or
they thought that this is terrible
you're ruining typescript are you
ruining JavaScript turning it into Java
you're doing all of these things they
shouldn't be doing
I want this freedom of a dynamic
language what today I think people have
really turned the corner instead of the
typescript things kind of cool so I
think that's kind of the premise of this
talk is just those things so you know
just a reminder like why do we use
typescript and why is types for
potentially a good thing well compared
to every other sort of attempt at fixing
javascript typescript doesn't really try
to fix it it tries to work with what's
there it tries to provide a duck type
system on top of JavaScript rather than
saying I'm going to give you a new
language that's going to generate
horrible to reach on the script I'm
gonna take JavaScript and add some
features to it and most people think of
types but I think of interfaces and
interfaces are a form of a type but the
whole point to me and why we use
typescript is for the interfaces and
that's because in JavaScript we have no
way to express intent to the block of
code and why does that matter well it
matters for interoperability it matters
when you say I need to swap this
dependency out with something else
because it's too slower it's no longer
meeting my needs but I don't want to
break my entire application architecture
right and so if I know the interface I
know what methods and properties are
there and what's supported I can replace
it whereas if I don't I sort of think I
know and then I run into every edge case
that someone clever extended in this
particular way now people used to take
dojo workshops years ago for me and they
would ask me questions like well okay
how do i express my intent and my code
and I'm like well you write really good
documentation and that's not really an
answer but then the better question
would be where's my intellisense or
where's my autocomplete and I have a
very good memory I'm like you're just
supposed to remember every method and
property and what they all do at your
head and that's like the perfect way to
learn JavaScript and people would look
at me like I was insane
but that's kind of how my mind works but
having intellisense and auto-completion
makes it so it's less about the
specifics of a particular API and it's
more about understanding the concepts
that you're trying to use and use them
efficiently so typescript and how many
of you use BS code so Wow almost
everyone so you've probably noticed in
the past six months or so that even when
you're working with plain JavaScript it
can tell you like when you're being
inconsistent or when you're doing things
that might not make sense and that's
because they've written a set of tools
using the typescript
language services to analyze your code
and sort of look at what you're doing
and try to help you to write better code
and they're also able to do that before
playing JavaScript I'll just type script
which is pretty cool so I think that you
know when you think about it
typescript is a duck typing system so
it's not saying okay I've got an
instance of say a class or a hook or
whatever cuz you know class is a bad
word and reactive but I don't care if
that instance or that version of it was
generated from this original Factory for
that right I just care does it have
these methods and properties of this
shape that matched my expected API so
duck typing means like to look like a
duck doesn't quack like a duck trip to
duck right not you know is it
genetically identical to a duck just for
the purpose of the API footprint that
matters does it match all the methods of
properties that a duck should have so if
you wanted to get started with reactant
type script you know a few months ago it
would have been a really painful answer
what if they like do all these things
and now it's just like oh well cool now
I can just use to create react up - -
type script and I'm done a line of
course you know some npm installs and
whatnot right but that's pretty cool
because I never thought that day would
happen right because react was so
focused on flow for so long or so
focused on some other other languages
that they use for various things so it
wasn't always that easy most
reference applications don't use this
yet because this is what a few weeks old
that this has actually been supported
officially if that I think it was
announced it react conf was that last
week or the week before so relatively
recently but that's a much simpler way
to get started I don't yet know if I
agree with all the decisions that come
out of the box using that approach but
again it's like now is a default feature
that's built into the main way that you
start off creating wrapped apps so I
guess what I'm trying to say is you know
if I'd given this talk six months ago
this would have been like ten slides
explaining like how to configure all
these different things and now I can
just say we'll just go use the create
rack down version rather than like one
of 50 different attempts at creating
create react app wow I can't even say
that quickly enough CRA will call that I
couldn't think of it you know there's so
many different iterations of versions
where people express their typescript
opinion but getting that built into the
version of create react app that
everyone uses means that hopefully
you'll get some sort of standardization
consolidation around that alright so the
other sort of thing I so how many of you
started using typescript more than two
years ago
okay so almost no longer how about one
year ago okay within the past six months
okay
so pretty steady progression but almost
no one more than two years ago and I
think that's pretty reasonable because I
think that typescript in 2016 was really
rough for react users there were a lot
of things that just felt wrong or happy
or unfinished or difficult to do and I'm
just going to quickly go through some of
the items that were fixed as typescript
has evolved to sort of show why I think
that typescript is a good thing for
react users so the first one actually I
push too fast sorry go back if too many
animations
okay so typescript 2.0 is released in
September of 2016 so just a little over
two years ago and before this the
biggest complaint
then I heard from reactive users wise
okay when I use flow I can incrementally
add type definitions but with typescript
I have to specify that everything is a
string or a number or boolean or all of
these things even if it's obvious even
if it's a constant or even if there's no
way that this thing is anything other
than the type that can be obviously
inferred and so with 2.0 the big
announcement was huge improvements to
control flow analysis and control flow
analysis is basically the process by
inspecting the code and trying to
understand what's going on about it
without you having to explicitly specify
everything about your code and what type
it is so at this point that argument
went away right the argument of will
flow is better because I don't have to
specify Const x equals 10 I don't have
to insert that it's a number or I don't
have to insert them as an integer or a
string or whatever I want it to be I can
infer it specifically by the fact that
it's a constant and it's very clear what
it is so that kind of removed that one
layer of unknowingness
and what was interesting is all old
react all old like react plus typescript
or just any types of code in general
that was at that time specifying all of
those things was now getting a bunch of
error message to saying hey idiot I know
it's a string I know it's a number
whereas before like two versions before
it was like hey tell me if that's a
number or a string so it was a nice flip
and making it easier and more ergonomic
to work with 2.1 came out two months
later so typescript generally releases
every two months except when it's like
it falls around December or it falls
around like and there's needing to take
a public holiday or something I don't
know but what's well it's three months
but they they release with a pretty
regular cadence which is really good
because it's predictable and what they
added was this sort of foundation for
meta programming in JavaScript and they
have this key of query sort of indexed
accessors I assume you understand the
syntax as most if you work with
typescript and sort of mapped objects
and those made a much better model
libraries that were more functional in
nature such as react or dojo or ember or
low - and so on and then they also added
a few different types but the one that
was in
Fortin was partial and without partial
it was really difficult to sort of have
a state that was partially specified and
then got updated with more details later
so it implement it made it much easier
to sort of say this is the type I all
need a subset of that type for this
thing to be valid and then over time
more information can be passed in as
part of this bigger interface so partial
is really just a subset of a full
interface and saying it's valid as long
as it conforms to this full interface or
some subset of it so that 2.2 came out a
couple months later and it didn't really
do a lot in terms of like hey I may
react better but it may react native
work the way it should and the main
distinction there was take my typescript
code and convert it to JavaScript but
leave my JSX onion compile and run
transform because I want to handle that
in like my normal sort of react native
workflow so what you start to see is
like in the early days of react with
typescript it was like okay we got Janus
X support we're done and that wasn't
really enough right so it's kind of
looking at how to deke couple the JSX
from react because JSX isn't just a
react thing right it's a language syntax
that could be used and is used by
pre-act and dojo and other libraries as
well so then 2.3 km and it had default
type arguments which makes it much
easier to sort of manage the case where
I've got some properties and then maybe
I've got some state that this thing
cares about or maybe I'm just using that
state to pass it further down my tree so
what it did is to sort of let you say
you know I've got a component that's a
class and I've got a couple of generic
parameters one of them is my properties
the second one's my state that state has
a default of say just a generic object
that then can add it to over time and so
what that did is it made it much easier
to express how a components type was
defined before this release before this
update you might have like 15 different
definitions trying to describe how this
one class was defined
and then this squashed it down to one so
one of the nice things about typescript
I find is that whenever they find
scenarios where it's like wow the user
has to write this really long list of
things to try to describe how this
particular API should work they go in
and they look at how they can simplify
that and parameterize that so you can
write it more generically or more
abstractly so that you're not writing
what feels like tedious old-style Java
clastic definitions of top which to me
pretty much scares everyone away from
the language that's actually part of a
bigger class of problems called berry
Edit kinds which is sort of a collection
of problems which is how do i define a
way to dynamic describe very dynamic
features very functional features so
like higher-order functions that return
API is that themselves generate
higher-order functions and so on and so
forth and the challenge with that is not
that it's impossible to do that with
typescript or that they couldn't add all
those use cases in now the challenge is
how do I make it fast enough to make it
so that the IDE can autocomplete without
it feeling like eclipse but you know
whatever wants to use because it's like
terribly slow right
maybe eclipse is fast now but the last
time I used it it was like I could see
it thinking while I was typing and they
want you to have the your IDE whenever
you're using with typescript be able to
compete up with how fast you can type in
things so the idea is they will not
introduce any feature since the language
that can not be made super fast which i
think is a really good thing because
it's a nice strong relationship not a
strict correlation but a really strong
relationship to say we're going to
create a type system that works with
what javascript is but that is so fast
that it won't get in your way so I think
that's a really good design so then
things evolved and started to improve
some more and 2.6 to 2.8 basically late
last year to early this year had three
releases that kind of improve the way
things work with JSP JSX
so one was before 2.6 I think you had to
have a full JSX frag like definition you
couldn't have like a frag
so it's really difficult to describe oh
I'm going to pull in this Deus Ex
fragment conditionally if I do this
versus that and then a lot of the sort
of completion list includes four like
this and brackets and curlies for JSX
weren't really well supported the pragma
comments make it so that you can specify
a different JSX parser different JSX
definition per file so the idea of being
like hey i want to combine some code
from react and react or react in dojo
but they might treat JSX a little bit
differently so i want to be able to
parse them differently and specify that
so yeah that's kind of with what
happened there then 2.9 came along and
it fixed tag template strings a bit
better allowing you to type your
arguments for templates so before this
released i would have made the argument
that JSX was not and template strings in
general were not a great way to work
with typescript because you really
couldn't express everything you could
from like a pure sort of functional
approach so you know you've got like
create react subclass I remember that's
exactly what's called but basically
hyper scripts sort of the alternative
JSX which is more of a functional
notation it's always been easier to type
because instead of having a template you
have function calls that have parameters
so they're easier to reason about what
they this sort of leveled that and this
is commonly used in sort of style
components or styled components and
stuff like that so that there are
lengthy examples showing this in the
various type script release posts so I
probably don't need to repeat those here
but basically one by one they've just
been looking for things that people
complain about and fixing them it's just
really nice and then the past few months
a big addition was supporting default
props for JSX
and then having it easier to describe
properties on function declarations
basically having your default props
working there and so again it was like
just one of those things where you
to write some very verbose code to try
to express the type definitions for this
and now it's considerably easier now
23.2 is coming out it's due this one but
because the u.s. Thanksgiving holiday I
don't know when they'll really still so
release it before Thanksgiving or after
Thanksgiving my guess would be
afterwards because Thanksgiving is a bit
early this year but anyway the very
attic kinds thing they made a big big
big breakthrough on strict bind call and
apply methods on functions I cannot do
this justice in 30 minutes let alone two
hours because it's a very complex topic
but I would go and read about it because
it's another big change that fixes like
a whole class of things where I can't
easily provide these definitions and so
forth so I it's one of those challenges
is when people like what's the one of
the benefits of typescript right and I
think well okay my team writes more
consistent code I have interfaces I find
errors earlier and so forth right but
like what's a specific react use case
where when I don't have typescript I'm
kind of annoyed and the best one I can
come up with is sort of prop types and
so having to define and use custom prop
types in normal JavaScript versus doing
it with a typescript interface to me
feels really tedious and typescript
interface feels very precise and
consistent I guess the other thing that
was interesting is when Juho mentioned
that you know he's been using typescript
for three months and who doesn't like
writing JavaScript anymore
and it's really interesting because I
mean typescript really is just a small
superset of JavaScript and what it is is
it's really a set of linting tools and
documentation tools and code accuracy
tools some of which are expressed in the
form of language features right so yeah
you've got this generic notation and
you've got these interfaces and you've
got these type definitions and you've
got support for some new features but
most of it's just es6 or yes 2017 or 18
or whatever but what's really neat is
that some of the features you just get
by using typescript and some of them
even work
JavaScript as well you know some of the
tooling around code consistency and
accuracy and describing how API is work
and so forth is provided by the tooling
rather than something you have to do so
it's kind of part language addition part
transpiler part static analysis tool and
part code later so it typescript is
really kind of all four of those things
sort of working together to create
better code so I have a github URL to an
example application it's not the world's
best react application but it's an
application that tries to do a number of
different things with react and redux
create some web components and do some
other things so it's just a reference
app if you want to look at it and it we
did this as part of a so we have clients
who come to us and say hey should I use
and so for the past 20 years it should I
use X Y or Z write an x y&z change over
time but the answer always is I don't
know what are you trying to do what are
you trying to achieve so there are
companies where react would not be a
great idea for them because they can't
agree on anything react to freeform for
them or there are companies where they
really want something that's very
specific to a particular framework and
reacted other frameworks are very
general purpose but this comparison came
about from a customer saying I want to
consider view dojo angular and react and
we know we want to use typescript so the
concern at the time this was about a
year ago was hey is typescript and react
are they going to work well together
because most of the examples don't use
of the time dangerous typescript and so
we basically did the legwork and showing
where the differences and similarities
were and because JavaScript and type
scriptures are flexible the four
examples start to look quite similar
because we're able to sort of turn
angular into something a bit more like
react and we're able to you know just
make things work the way we would want
them to work but it also highlights the
differences and distinctions between the
approach we took and then we just
dated the react one and time for this
talk so it's current so it's not a year
old it's it's highway say it's a little
best world's best application but again
it's just another example to look at now
I mentioned that I work on dojo so I'm
not here to really sell you on dojo I'm
just here to tell you what to do is so
how many of you used dojo one like back
in the day before react so a handful of
people
okay so shares the name but the history
is really interesting so in 2008
Facebook hired site behind their company
to teach them how to write JavaScript
and so we went to this hotel in Palo
Alto and trained face books for 126 to
427 engineers on how to write JavaScript
the one who skipped was Mark Zuckerberg
cuz he didn't training at that point and
so we basically spent two days with 13
teaching them how to write JavaScript
care and we've taught them in a way that
was very opinionated and very different
and varied dojo but we didn't tell them
to use dojo because it was Facebook and
they needed to do their own thing and so
what was interesting though is they use
dojo for awhile and there were things
they liked about dojo they liked sort of
the component model like the cult
component model thing comes from dojo
but dojo didn't invent that that comes
from like Laszlo reflects right which
then comes from Delphi everything goes
back to Delphi eventually or interface
builder right so like the whole web
components thing and the react
components thing that's been done like
50 times before in different programming
languages but it's been reinvented at
least four or five times in JavaScript
as well too gets worked out today anyway
the point is so there were two sort of
seminal projects early in the day that
did the equivalent of virtual dog
dipping without really doing it the way
we do today
there was dojo which had a vector
graphics implementation that would
support SVG canvas Silverlight or vml
and then there was this tool called
bespin which was a canvas based code
editor that virtualized real time rich
text editing but rendered it to canvas
which that later became cloud 9 which is
now Amazon's Cloud 9 code editor anyway
both of those projects virtualized the
Dom but for
just like a component on a page or just
a specific set and the reason you didn't
really think hey I'm going to do this
for my whole application or my whole
page was because ie six through eight
sucked right so the memory allocation
you had for those old browsers is so
small but if you try to do what you do
today with react in a whole page you
would instantly be thrown into garbage
collection mode and you would have no
resources available for your application
but as soon as you could liberate I used
six through eight from your stack this
idea of making the entire page
virtualized in memory is actually really
powerful and really cool so by 2013 it
was roughly the time when people stopped
asking about ie8 support so it was a
really good time to make that transition
so long story short dojo did some of the
stuff react does early on and then about
five years ago we decided it was time to
start thinking about dojo too and so we
started a rewrite we rewrote about six
or seven times and we kept asking
ourselves what should dojo be because if
we're gonna create this thing we want
something that we really want to use so
sort of the foundational pieces where we
want a typescript framework that's
relevant for the enterprise we really
like what react does because react
really liked what dojo did we like the
virtual Dom approach we like you know
the sort of component model we like
reactive State but there are some things
we don't like about react one of which
is sort of when I need to do things with
a Dom element that are not like I need
to change the dimensions of something or
I want to use an intersection observer
on a Dom component or I want to do a web
animation the typical default react
answer is fine use this sort of crufty
way to get access to the Dom element to
just go to town the dojo way is to say
okay we've gone through all those use
cases and we provide those as properties
you can reactive so if you need a web
animation we're going to give you the
properties back that would get from a
web animation and you can react to this
if you need to resize a node we're going
to give you properties for the
dimensions rather than one Dominic if
you need an intersection observer we're
going to tell you a property on whether
something is inside something else or
not so we've looked at things we just
they're probably big difference between
reactives we've tried to put together a
more comprehensive framework not a
kitchen sink framework like angular but
more of a this is the router this is the
component model this is the virtual Dom
system like these are the this is the
build system the build system by default
so there's a comparison on the real
world reference application so real
world is a collection of reference
applications people have written for a
bunch of different frameworks and
someone wrote a comparison of all of
them this year and dojo is faster and
smaller than react than angular than
pretty much everything else but it's
because we cheat and I say that we
achieved in a nice way and that we
basically we look at your default routes
and your default components and we
optimized for your first initial paint
by creating a really small bundle size
so we do code splitting based on your
application itself rather than you
having to go through the process of
doing all that work manually so the idea
really is we've said all right if we
were to rewrite react or we were to
rewrite dojo rewrite react rewrite on
the frameworks what would we end up with
and we would end up with something good
job so I'm not saying any of you should
ever use Ojo but it's worth a look if
you're interested in sort of how we do
it I mean it uses JSX syntax uses
typescript it renders the default
function so for a react developer it's
very quick to jump in and sort of
understand what we're doing but again I
think the biggest thing to take away
from sort of reactive typescript is
those two technologies have kind of
taken over but they don't have to
dominate it can influence everything
else as well so that's a good thing
so I that is 29 minutes and 24 seconds
that's pretty spot-on it's so cool thank
you